battery style timeout here it's very
cold once we run out of batteries we
can't drop a bar we can't just walk in
and flip on a switch here there's no
switch alright so the generators we use
out here Wiseman the power our charging
station inside our cabin here yep
definitely empty so we're going to need
to go to our barrel get some more fuel
lock cozy to keep everything powered up
here in Wiseman brought with us
55-gallon barrels of gas and we pretty
much have to fill up that generator to
time today the batteries die all the
time out here they can just be in your
pocket be full charge when you pulled
out a pocket two hours later if you
chose one bar it takes us about a gown
gown and a half every 12 hours to keep
the generator running yeah it's a wild
lift out with three cameras going to run
through batteries like mad all day hey
Danny looks like we're getting pretty
for here head back over fill up that
Genny
alright we're all full here give your
clothes done fire back up and ready to
charge some batteries gotta fire back up
to be a few poles she's definitely cold
batteries are all charged up cameras are
ready to go we're ready to take our
cameras and go film Erik Martha and get
another episode negative 9 we're gonna
be going after some fur anyway you can
avoid detection is good
we're currently painting these brand-new
snow machines white orders by chip
hailstone to camo our rods can you even
see them they're pure white they match
can't really tell the difference between
the snow and ice fairing we're gonna be
going after Super Bowls and Wolverines
and things that possibly can see color
and so chip and Agnes have their snow
machines painted white as camerman we're
paying our snow machines white as well
so we can follow them and we want to we
want to fade into the tundra just like
they do we're looking at the thermometer
over there is negative nine not ideal
conditions and here we are
spray-painting them in the field these
the problems you experience when you're
spray-painting in a zero degree
temperature things freeze
all right we got about 25 minutes before
sunset wonderful with these drugs it's
going to drop for like- this row machine
spinning light
stay close to the hailstones undetected
you